okay it's fair to say video game movies
are pretty crappy one bum or fraud times
sake
[Music]
the latest in what is an incredibly long
line of games of film adaptations is
Assassin's Creed you saw slag ship
franchise that everyone and their mums
is heard about well except for the star
Michael Fassbender apparently
and while the franchise might be one of
the most popular and video games history
is five facts that you might not know
about assassin's creed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
while the quality of the Assassin's
Creed movie remains yet to be seen if
there's one thing you can give 20th
Century Fox and Ubisoft credit for is
that they went the extra mile for
authenticity next two hoods with beaks
wrist mounted ships and holy ships that
are sent from the seabed the leap of
faith is one of the most iconic aspects
of Assassin's Creed
so in realizing the AC Universe
on-screen director Justin Curzon
insisted that the leap of faith be
recreated in real life and settled
through computer-generated wizardry as a
result the movie features one of the
highest free Falls performed by a
stuntman in almost 35 years the actual
jump was performed by damien walters who
is basically as close to an actual
assassin as you're gonna get waters is
an expert at jumping of stuff at a
height that would make most people poop
themselves even thinking about he's
performed stunts in movies like kick-ass
Skyfall and Captain America the First
Avenger this however was his most daring
yet and if you're sitting there thinking
I bet it's not all that difficult I'm
here to tell you it absolutely is I was
fortunate enough to be on the set of the
Assassin's Creed movie when Damien did
the jump and just seeing him standing on
a platform over a hundred and twenty
feet in the air made my survival
instincts kick in I was scared for the
guy but being a consummate professional
damien wasn't fazed he donned the iconic
Assassin's outfit hopped on a platform
and knocked out a couple of warm-up
jumps from 70 feet and ninety feet
before leaping off at 125 feet and
plummeting into a little inflatable mat
at ground level and when he was done I
found him wrapping up cables and
clearing up the set why hero
[Applause]
[Music]
you bazoft share the development of the
Assassin's Creed games between
approximately a billion studios so it
makes sense for the games to have a
shared universe - as there's been Blum
Corp and Abstergo crossover emails that
suggests that watchdogs and Assassin's
Creed are set at the same time and of
course all the Assassin's games are
connected to using a nifty little plot
device called the animus naturally the
new assassin's creed movie will leap of
faith into the same muddy gene pool as
the video games comics and books head of
Assassin's Creed content EEMA as isaiah
took over the official AC twitter
account look you've got a bluetick so
you know it's legit to tease some
tidbits of information about how they
intersect we share the same universe
element in the film have consequences as
in our games comics and books solid use
of the Oxford comma and when asked if we
see any characters from the games in the
film it's a brand new story with new
characters set in our universe it's
possible you may find some familiar
faces there is present day you will
definitely see Abstergo and about
assassins well nothing is impossible I'm
not expecting a year or the Frey twins
to stumble into shot but I do want to
see some references to my beloved Ezio
maybe like a statuette on the shelf or
someone drinking a latte a little bitter
if you ask me just seems lacking somehow
I don't know have you considered that
Dean sugar maybe a latte
[Music]
Assassin's Creed is a series that draws
heavy inspiration from real-life history
this is most evident in its settings and
some of the key historical figures that
make cameos but something that
unfortunately isn't explored in as much
depth as we'd like is the order of the
assassins itself buckle up folks it's
time for a lesson on the etymology of
the word assassin assassin is derived
from the Arabic word machine which means
those who are faithful to the foundation
it was used to refer to the Nizari
Ismaili x' which was a secret order that
formed after the fracturing of the Shia
branch of Islam the group went about
capturing areas of Persia and Syria
under the leadership of Hassani Sabbah
amanda inspired the creation of al
mualim al tires mentor in the first
Assassin's Creed like al mualim's sävar
was a keen student of astronomy and
metaphysical matters which Ubisoft
channeled in al mualim's quest for the
apple of Eden within the Hashashin was a
group called the Fedayeen which means
those who would sacrifice themselves the
Fedayeen were known for being silent and
deadly striking with precision and often
opting to force their enemies to submit
instead of killing them outright the
methods employed by the Hashshashin
and the Fedayeen continued to be used in
modern guerrilla warfare and in video
games for people who loved to stab dudes
in the face and neck shank style like
synchronization achieve
regression
psychology isn't all Rorschach tests and
wanting to bang your mum sorry to burst
that bubble in fact Assassin's Creed
take some inspiration from a pretty cool
psychological theory called collective
unconscious in the games you use a
machine called the animus to dip into
your genetic memories and relive the
lives of your ancestors either for
funsies on offeri a-- swirled controls
is the theory of collective unconscious
was thought up by Swiss psychiatrist
Carl Jung who stated that all the
unconscious Minds you know the bit that
wants to bang your mom of the same
species have shared memories and
experiences ac take this one step
further by using the genetic memory to
provide instructions from the ancestor
to the descendant which is how desmond
can learn to be an assassin just by
reliving i'll tire and Ezio's memories
within the animus things that would take
years to learn in real life take a
matter of days in the Animus anyway
there's been a lot of debate about the
existence of such an unconscious well I
mean the difficulty there lies in the
fact that as an unconscious by
definition you can't access it and
you're not really aware but it's there
but anyway Abstergo referenced this
openly in the game by hoping that their
discovery of genetic memory will put an
end to that debate once a brawl if only
real psychology had all the answers Oh
how's three years well spent I found
proof
proof of what
but nothing is true and everything is
permitted
come destroy the betrayer nothing is
true everything is permitted is the
Creed of the assassins but also features
heavily in the inspiration of the series
the boot alamos by vladimir Bartol okay
so the actual line is nothing as an
absolute reality all is permitted but
considering the novel came out in the
30s we could excuse some minor
alterations to the maxim the book alla
moot was a massive influence to the
Assassin's Creed series and is set in
the 11th century alla fortress of Alamut
the story follows to hear who wants to
join the four died a group of soldiers
that obey without question believing
they ascend to heaven when they die duty
as the story goes on in the fortresses
besieged is discovered these soldiers
have been manipulated they are given
hashish and carried into the heavenly
Gardens in their comatose state so they
believe their leader has the power of
God so basically the way the apple of
Edom is used in the first Assassin's
Creed game was basically just drugs in
the book but though to be fair I don't
think I could jump into a hay bale sober
so those are five facts about the
Assassin's Creed series that you might
not have known about if you have more
Assassin's Creed fun facts make sure you
leave in the comment section below and
for more videos like this make sure you
subscribe to GameSpot universe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]